THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATION TODAY
WILL BE HOLDING AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON TO
TRIBAL STATE COMPACT THE FIRST
IS WITH THE MIDDLETOWN
RANCHERIA AND THE SECOND WITH
THE SANTA ROSA INDIAN COMMUNITY
ALSO KNOWN AS THE TETCHY YOLK
AT TRIBE FOR THOSE OF YOU
UNFAMILIAR WITH THE SENATE'S
PROCEDURE. THE ESTABLISHED-
POLICY ALLOWS FOR INFORMATIONAL
HEARING ON THE DETAILS OF THE
COMPACT TO BE FOLLOWED BY A
VOTE ON THE FLOOR SENATE FLOOR.
NO VOTE WILL BE TAKEN HERE
TODAY THE VEHICLE FOR
RATIFICATION OF THESE CONTACTS
WILL BE A. B. NINE FIFTY SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SOLACE IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT ALL THESE
COMPACT'S MIRROR MANY OF THE
RECENT COMPACTS THAT HAVE COME
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE THIS
INCLUDES ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION LANGUAGE LABOR
PROVISIONS ALLOW WORKERS TO
UNIONIZE PROVISIONS THAT ALLOW
FOR OFF RESERVATION MITIGATION
AND LANGUAGE THAT ESTABLISHES A
PROCESS IF DISPUTES WERE TO
ARISE I DO WANT TO NOTE THAT
NORMALLY WE WOULD DO EACH
CONTACT INDIVIDUALLY BUT TO
FACILITATE THE PROCESS WE ARE
GOING TO CHANGE THINGS UP A BIT
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH
NATHAN WELL GALLEY INTERIM
TRIBAL NEGOTIATIONS ADVISER
FOR- GOVERNOR NEWSOM WHO WILL
PRESENT BOTH COMPACTS HE WILL
BE FOLLOWED BY- JOSE SIMON THE
THIRD CHAIRMAN OF THE
MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA FOLLOWING
CHAIRMAN SIMON WE WILL HEAR
FROM LEO CISCO CHAIRMAN OF THE
SANTA ROSA INDIAN COMMUNITY
THAT WILL FOLLOW B. FOLLOWED BY
MARIO YOU DIVA AND KRISTEN
MARTIN FROM UNITE HERE IT WILL
FINISH OFF WITH PUBLIC COMMENT
FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN L.
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
1-877-336-4437 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS EIGHT TWO SIX. EIGHT
FOUR TWO EIGHT. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
INDOOR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. I
UNDERSTAND THE MISERABLE
GALLEONS ON ZOOM THE SERVO
GELLING FREE FEEL FREE TO BE
YET. GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN DON
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU MY
NAME IS MEGAN VOCALLY AND I AND
IT AND TERM TRAVEL NEGOTIATIONS
ADVISER FOR THE GOVERNOR
GOVERNOR FILLING IN FOR ANNA
NAME MARK. I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GO OVER THE
TRIBAL STATE GAMING COMPACT FOR
THE MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA AND
THE SANTA ROSA RANCHERIA. I'D
ALSO LIKE TO THANK MIDDLETOWN
RANCHERIA CHAIR SIMON AND SANTA
ROSA RANCH RICHER CISCO FOR
THEIR EFFORTS TO FINALIZE THESE
COMPACTS THE SANTA ROSA
RANCHERIAS LOCATED IN KINGS
COUNTY AND CURRENTLY OPERATES
APPROXIMATELY TWO THOUSAND
GAMING DEVICES OF THE TACHI
PALACE CASINO RESORT. THE
MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIAS LOCATED
IN LAKE COUNTY ND OPERATES THE
TWIN PINE CASINO WHICH HAS JUST
UNDER THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
GAMING DEVICES BOTH OF THESE
TRIBES ARE ENGAGED AND SUPPORT
ACTIVITIES IN THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITY THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
IS NOT AWARE OF LOCAL
OPPOSITION TO THE COMPACT AS
AUTHORIZED UNDER PROP ONE A.
WHICH APPROVED TRIBAL OPERATION
OF SLOT MACHINES BANKING IN
PERCENTAGE CARD GAMES AND
LOTTERY GAMES ON INDIAN LANDS.
THE GOVERNOR NEGOTIATED THESE
CONTACTS SUBJECT TO LEGISLATIVE
RATIFICATION THE TWO COMPACTS
SIGNED IN APRIL TWENTY TWENTY
ONE CONTAIN THE ELEMENTS
TRADITIONALLY INCLUDED IN PRIOR
RATIFIED CONTACTS THAT ARE
TAILORED FOR EACH TRIBE CARE
WAS TAKEN TO DEVELOP RESPECTFUL
LANGUAGE THAT ADDRESSES
TRAVELING STATE CONCERNS BY
REGULARISING EXISTING TRAVEL
POLICIES IN GAMING REQUIREMENTS
THIS IS REFLECTIVE OF THE
GOVERNMENT TO GOVERNMENT NATURE
OF THE TRIBAL STATE
RELATIONSHIPS THE COMPACT EARNS
OR TWENTY FIVE YEARS MAN
CLEARED NOW STANDARD FORCE
MAJOR LANGUAGE TO ADDRESS
REDUCED OPERATIONS ARE CLOSURES
FROM EPIDEMICS AND PANDEMICS
UNDER THE NEW CONTACTS SANTA
ROSA RANCHERIA WILL BE ABLE TO
OPERATE UP TO THREE THOUSAND
TOTAL GAMING DEVICES ACROSS
THREE FACILITIES. FOR
MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA CAN
OPERATE TWELVE HUNDRED GAMING
DEVICES ACROSS TWO FACILITIES
BOTH TRIBES WILL BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR A PRO RATA SHARE OF
PAYMENTS TO THE SPECIAL
DISTRIBUTION FIND OR STF. WHICH
HELP TO REIMBURSE THE STATE FOR
ITS REGULATORY AND OTHER DIRECT
COSTS OF TRIBAL GAMING
MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIAS COMPACT
PROVIDES FOR A CREDIT AGAINST
ITS SDF OBLIGATION IN
RECOGNITION OF ITS PRIOR
PREPAYMENT OF FEES FOR UNUSED
GAME LICENSES SANTA ROSA
RANCHERIA WHEN OPERATING MORE
THAN TWELVE HUNDRED GAMING
DEVICES WILL CONTRIBUTEFOUR
AND A QUARTER PERCENT OF ITS
GROSS GAMING REVENUE OVER THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY DEVICES. TO
THE REVENUE SHARING TRUST FUND
FOR THE R. S. YES RCF ANNUALLY
DISTRIBUTES ONE POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS EACH LIMITED
AND NON GAMING TRIBES IN
CALIFORNIA. FINDS PAGES ARE STF
MAY BE DISBURSED THROUGH AWARDS
FROM THE TRIBAL NATIONS GRANT
FUND. THE LIMITED AND NON
GAMING TRIBES AS WELL SANTA
ROSA RANCHERIAS ABLE TO CREDIT
AGAINST ITS RST OBLIGATION ITS
PAYMENTS TO LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
FOR SERVICES RELATED TO SUCH
THINGS AS FIRE MEDICAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND EDUCATION. AND
FOR PAYMENTS SUPPORTING HOUSING
FOR ITS ELDERS AND FOR PEOPLE
IN FINANCIAL NEED CONTACTS
INCLUDE STANDARD CONTROLS TO
ENSURE FAIR PLAY HONESTY AND
INTEGRITY IN OPERATIONS SUCH AS
FACILITY AN EMPLOYEE LICENSING
AND GAMING REGULATIONS. MINORS
ARE PROHIBITED FROM GAINING OR
PURCHASING TOBACCO PRODUCTS IN
THE TRIBE'S ALCOHOL SALES AND
PURCHASES WILL COMPLY WITH
STATE LAWS CONSISTENT WITH
OTHER RECENT CONTACTS THESE
CONTACTS ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
TRIBAL SOVEREIGNTY BY
INCORPORATING RATHER THAN
DIRECTING TRIBAL LAW. THE
CONTACTS FOR EXAMPLE INCLUDE
TRIBAL ORDINANCES FOR PAGER
DISPUTES COURTS AND EMPLOYMENT
DISCRIMINATION WITH AGREEABLE
DUE PROCESS PROVISIONS
ADDITIONALLY THE TRIBE'S COMMIT
TO MINIMUM WAGE STANDARDS AT
LEAST AS STRINGENT AS
CALIFORNIANS BOTH CONTRACTS
REQUIRE THE TRIBES TO MAINTAIN
A TRIBAL LABOR RELATIONS
ORDINANCE FOR T. O. R. M. S. T.
O. R. OWES WHICH TAKE A FACT
THAT THE TWO INTERNS FIFTY
EMPLOYEE THRESHOLD EXCLUDING
TRIBAL MEMBERS. ARE THE SAME AS
OTHERS RECENTLY APPROVED BY THE
LEGISLATURE T. R. O. FUNCTIONS
AS A MECHANISM FOR A BILATERAL
CONTRACTS BETWEEN THE TRIBE AND
THE LABOR ORGANIZATION IF THE
LABOR ORGANIZATION ACCEPTS THE
ENTIRETY OF THE TIARA THEN THEY
TRIED TO MINUTES TO BINDING
ARBITRATION FOR COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AND OTHER DISPUTES.
THE TRIBE FURTHER COMMITS
DURING THE NOTICE OF INTENT TO
ORGANIZE PERIOD NOT TO STATE
OPPOSITION TO A COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT OR A
PARTICULAR UNION. THE LABOR
ORGANIZATION FOR ITS PART
AGREES NOT TO STRIKER PICKET AT
THE TRIBE'S CASINO OR ATTEMPT
TO INFLUENCE THE ELECTION.
EITHER PARTY MAY GO TO COURT TO
COMPEL ARBITRATION OR
COMPLIANCE WITH AN ARBITRATION
AWARD ALSO CONSISTENT WITH
PRIOR RECENT CONTACTS BASED ON
FACTS INCORPORATE ROBUST
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW PROCEDURES
FOR POTENTIAL OFF RESERVATION
IMPACTS ALLOW THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACT
REVIEW PROCESS ALLOWING FOR
CATEGORICAL EXEMPTIONS AND
NEGATIVE DECLARATIONS THE TRIBE
IS NOT ABLE TO SUFFICIENTLY
MITIGATE IMPACTS THE METRA MUST
COMPLETE A TRIBAL ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT REPORT AND COME TO AN
INTER GOVERNMENTAL AGREEMENT
WITH THE LOCAL CITY COUNTY OR
IN SOME INSTANCES THE STATE THE
MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA COMPACT
INCLUDES AN ALTERNATIVE PROCESS
IF THE TRIBE WILL BE OPERATING
NO MORE THAN THREE INTERNS
FORTY NINE GAMES. IT REQUIRES A
BINDING COMMITMENT BY THE TRIBE
TO THE STATE TO PERFORM ITS
OBLIGATIONS TO MITIGATE IMPACTS
THE LOCAL PUBLIC SERVICES
FINALLY BOTH CONTACTS INCLUDED
DISPUTE RESOLUTION PROCESS TO
ENFORCE CONTACT TERMS. IF BEST
EFFORTS BY THE TRIBE IN THE
STATE TO RESOLVE THE DISPUTE
THROUGH GOOD FAITH NEGOTIATIONS
DID NOT SUCCEED. COMPAQ'S CALL
FOR A MEET AND CONFER PROCESS
IF THAT'S UNSUCCESSFUL THAN THE
STATE AND TRIED ME VOLUNTARILY
ARBITRATE THE DISPUTE AS AN
ALTERNATIVE TO ARBITRATION THE
PARTY ALLEGING BREACH AFTER
GIVING THE OTHER PARTY AT
THIRTY DAY PERIOD TO CARE IN
FILING FEDERAL COURTS SEEKING A
DECLARATION OF A MATERIAL
BREACH. IF THE BREACHING PARTY
STILL HAS NOT CURED WITHIN
THIRTY DAYS-FINAL COURT ORDER
THAN THE NON BREACHING PARTY
CAN ASK THE COURT TO ORDER
TERMINATION OF THE TRIBAL STATE
COMPACT I'D LIKE TO CONCLUDE BY
AGAIN EXPRESSING APPRECIATION
FOR THE TRIBE'S EFFORTS TO
REACH AGREEMENT. AND FURTHER
OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW THESE
CONTACTS WITH THE COMMITTEE
TODAY. THANK YOU EVERY EVERYONE
FOR YOUR TIME AND AVAILABLE FOR
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU MR
ROVELLI- MEMBERS ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS I'M NOT SEEING ANY
QUESTIONS- ISRAELI I DO HAVE
ONE QUESTION- PRETTY MUCH ALL
I'M SURE ALL THE MEMBERS AND A
LOT OF MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
ARE. YOU HAVE BEEN SEEING
WHAT'S BEEN HAPPENING DOT IT'S
AKUA ON- I'M I'M WONDERING CAN
YOU DESCRIBE THE NATURE OF THE
LAWSUIT AND- WHEN WE CAN EXPECT
A FINAL RULE I KNOW IT'S NOT
TOTALLY SPECIFIC TO THIS ONE
COMPACT. BUT IN GENERAL IT'S
THIS IS CERTAINLY SOMETHING
THAT- IS ON THE TOP OF THE MIND
YEAH SURE I'LL BE HAPPY TO GIVE
HER REALLY BRIEF OVERVIEW. SO
IN THAT SITUATION- UNITE HERE-
PROVIDED SIX ONE THE TRIED.
THEIR OFFER DO YOU ACCEPT THE
T. L. R. O. IN ITS ENTIRETY AND
PROVIDED THEM WITH A NOTICE OF
INTENT TO ORGANIZED UNDER THE
TRIBAL LABOR RELATIONS
ORDINANCE. SYCUAN TOOK THE
POSITION THAT THAT T. L. R. O.
WAS PREEMPTED BY THE NATIONAL
LABOR RELATIONS ACT AT UNITE
HERE ULTIMATELYFILED SUIT IN
FEDERAL DISTRICT COURT TO
COMPEL ARBITRATION UNDER THAT
YELLOW ARROW. AT THE DISTRICT
COURT LEVEL THE COURT FOUND
THAT UNITE HERE IN SIX ONE HAD
FORMED A CONTRACT. REQUIRING
COMPLIANCE WITH THE T. L. R. O.
IN ORDER THE PARTY STARTED
STRAIGHT. SICK ONES APPEAL BACK
TO THE NINTH CIRCUIT COURT OF
APPEALS. LAST I KNOW THEY'RE
NICE CIRCUIT HAS NOT YET
SCHEDULED ORAL ARGUMENT IN THE
CASE I THINK PEOPLE ARE
EXPECTING IT MAYBE AROUND THE
END OF THIS YEAR BEGINNING OF
MAX- BUT NO TIMELINE
SPECIFICALLY ON A DECISION FOR
THATCASE. BUT BARRING A
DIFFERENT OUTCOME AT THE NINTH
CIRCUIT LEVEL SYCUAN AND UNITE
HERE REQUIRED TO GO THROUGH
ARBITRATION UNDER THE TLR- TO
RESOLVE THE ISSUES AS AS WAS
ORDERED BY A DISTRICT COURT.
ALTERNATELY IF THAT TRIED TO
CLIMB REFUSED TO COMPLY WITH
THAT AWARD. THEN UNITE HERE AND
BE ABLE TO PURSUE A COURT ORDER
CONFIRMING THE ARBITRATION
AWARD. I DON'T KNOW THAT THAT
TRIBAL LABOR RELATIONS
ORDINANCES INCLUDE SPECIFICALLY
LIMITED WAIVERS OF SOVEREIGN
IMMUNITY I TRIED TO ALLOW FOR
SUCH ENFORCEMENT AND COMPLIANCE
PURPOSES. VERY GOOD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THAT- NOW WE'LL
MOVE ON TO JOSE SIMON THE THIRD
TRIBAL CHAIR FOR THE MIDDLETOWN
RANCHERIA. I BELIEVE HE IS ALSO
ON SOON. CHAIRMAN WELCOME AND
POLICE BEGAN THANK YOU CHAIR
DOG IN MEMBERS WELL MY NAME IS
JOSE SIMON THE THIRD I ALSO GO
BY THE BOOK SIGN IN MY TRAVEL
MATE. ON THE CHAIRMAN OF
MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA BAND OF
POMO INDIANS AND I'M HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
EIGHTY NINE FIVE SEVEN- WHICH
WILL RATIFY HYDE AMENDMENT TO
THE MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA
TRIBE'S GAMING COMPACT WITH THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WANT TO
TAKE YOU SENATOR DODD. FOR YOUR
LONG SUPPORT IN Q. A
COOPERATION WITH THE MIDDLETOWN
RANCHERIA TRIBE ITS WILLINGNESS
TO HOLD THIS HEARING TODAY. TO
HEAR ABOUT THE UPDATED CONTACT
AS AS STATED MILTON RENTERIA IS
A SMALL- TRIBE TO ORDERED FORTY
ONE TRIBAL MEMBERS THAT IS
LOCATED IN LAKE COUNTY
CALIFORNIA. ARE WE ARE
RECOGNIZED TRIBE IN- NINETEEN
OH SIX WITH THE MIDDLETOWN
RANCHERIA BANDIT INDIANS OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE OPERATE A
SMALL GAMING FACILITY WITH LESS
THAN THREE HUNDRED FORTY NINE
OUR GOVERNMENT GAMING DEVICES
HERE IN LAKE COUNTY. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHT POINT EIGHT EMPLOYEES-
THERE ARE SIXTEEN TRIBAL
MEMBERS AND THE REST ARE
COMMUNITY WERE MURDERED MEMBERS
FROM OUR LOCAL AREA. WELL WE
ARE- ONE OF THE LARGER
EMPLOYERS IN OUR AREA. AND WE
HAVE ALWAYS TAKEN THE SAFETY
THE HEALTH CARE AND- THE
WELLBEING OF OUR EMPLOYEES TO
HEART- DURING THE TWENTY
FIFTEEN VALLEY FIRE ARE WE NOT
ONLY GOT TO- TALK ABOUT THOSE
THINGS THAT WE DO FOR OUR
COMMUNITY BUT WE GOT TO SHOW
THAT WE ARE HERE TO SUPPORT NOT
ONLY OUR TRIBAL MEMBERS. BUT
OUR ENTIRE SURROUNDING
COMMUNITY AS WE WERE DEVASTATED
BY THE TWENTY FIFTEEN VALLEY
FIRE IN. MY AREA SINCE THEN
SUBSEQUENTLY WE'VE HAD A
DISASTER WE'VE GOT THIRTEEN
DISASTERS- SINCE TWENTY FIFTEEN
HERE LOCALLY. AND WE CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT OUR COMMUNITY BY
OPERATING SHELTERS BY PROVIDING
SAFE EVEN DURING PS PS EVENTS
IN OTHER THINGS THAT ARE
AFFECTING OUR AREA. AS WE MOVE
FORWARD WITH THIS COMPACT THIS
WILL SOLIDIFY THEIR SOVEREIGN
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES FOR MY
PEOPLE. THIS IS THE SECOND
CONTACT THAT I HAVE NEGOTIATED
IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE I
NEGOTIATED THE NINETY NINE
CONTACT RIGHT ACROSS THE STREET
AT THE HIGH- WITH THE- THE
GOVERNOR WILLIAM NORRIS- THE
GOVERNORS. AT THAT TIME-
NEGOTIATOR AND I'M PROUD TO SAY
THAT WE HAD ANOTHER GREAT
NEGOTIATION WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN GOOD FAITH I WANT
TO TAKE THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
IN ANNA NAME MARK AS WE WORK
THROUGH THIS PROCESS IT WAS NOT
EASY- WITH COLBY WE DID A LOT
OF THE WORK REMOTELY- BUT WE
ARE WILLING AND READY TO MOVE
FORWARD. WITH A POSITIVE VOTE
TODAY THE NIGHT OR WHEN IT DOES.
HAPPEN THEY B. NINE FIVE SEVEN.
I TO YOU TODAY TO TALK ABOUT.
THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT WILL BE
GIVEN NOT ONLY TO THE
MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA BUT THE
LOCAL AREA. WE ARE CONTINUING
WITH OUR- GAMING- GROSS- AS
NEEDED- WE WILL BE ADDING SOME
AMENITIES HOPEFULLY IN THE
FUTURE WHICH WE GIVE DIFFERENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR JOBS- HERE
LOCALLY- WE ARE LOCATED IN ONE
OF THE POOREST COUNTIES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE WANT TO
CONTINUE JUST WITH OUR
OPPORTUNITIES TO GROW ECONOMIC
VIBRANCY FOR THE TRIAL. BUT
ALSO OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY- TO
HELP LAKE COUNTY- AS IT COMES
OUT OF ITS CURRENT FINANCIAL
SITUATION WITH THAT. I WILL GO
AHEAD AND OPEN UP FOR ANY
QESTIONS- AS WE GO FORWARD-
THERE- WELL THERE IS ONE MORE
THING I WILL WOULD LIKE TO TALK
ABOUT- THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC
I JUST WANT TO SAY IT.
MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA ENACTED-
COMPLETE CLOSURE BACK IN MARCH
OF TWENTY TWENTY EARLY ON WE
WERE CLOSE FOR THREE MONTHS
TILL JUNE. AND WHEN WE RE OPEN-
WE TOOK THE COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC VERY SERIOUSLY AND AS
OF TODAY WE STILL CURRENTLY YOU
DO NOT INDOOR FACILITY- WHETHER
ITS CUSTOMERS OR EMPLOYEES
WITHOUT A MASS WITHOUT A
TEMPERATURE CHECK. WE ALSO ARE
IMPLEMENTING WEEKLY- FAX IT
WEEKLY- TESTING- FOR COVERT. WE
ARE ALSO RUNNING A VACCINE
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS NOT ONLY FOR
OUR EMPLOYEES BUT ALSO ARE
LOOKING TO HELP AND WORK WITH
THE STATE. IN OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICER YOUR COURAGE FOLKS ARE
FOR VACCINATIONS- WE HAVE
BECOME A NON SMOKING FACILITY
AND WE PLAN TO CONTINUE THAT.
AS WE MOVE THROUGH THIS
PANDEMIC WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE A SAFE CLEAN
ENVIRONMENT. THAT REALLY ENJOY
THAT YOU CAN ENJOY WITHOUT
HAVING TO WORRY ABOUT ANY
OPPORTUNITIES OR ANYONE BEING
IN THE BUILDING- WITHOUT A MASK
ON SO WE JUST WANT TO TOUCH ON
THOSE ISSUES. AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO DO THAT LIFE AND
SAFETY IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING WE TAKE. TO HEART IN
MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA WE'LL DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO WORK WITH
OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO OFFER
OPPORTUNITIES TO HELP US MOVE
THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC SO WITH
THAT. WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE MY
STATEMENTS ONCE AGAIN YOUR DOG
THANK YOU FOR TODAY'S
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN- ANY MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS JUST AS OF PERSON
PRIVILEGE- I DID REPRESENT THE
MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA WHEN I WAS
IN THIS IN THE STATE ASSEMBLY-
JUST AN OUTSTANDING- AS
MITCHELL OFF OBVIOUSLY ALL ARE
BUT- I'VE- I'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH
CHAIRMAN WE CALL MOKE- HE'S
CALLED LOGIN- ALSO HE IS A
COUNTY SUPERVISOR IN LAKE
COUNTY AND- BOTH- I HAD A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT QUESTIONS
FOR YOU BUT YOU COVER THEM ALL
IN YOUR PRESENTATION AND I
MIGHT ADD. VERY VERY WELL I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU BEING WITH
US TODAY YET AT THIS POINT IN
TIME AND NOW WE'LL MOVE ON TO-
LEO CISCO CHAIR OF THE SANTA
ROSA INDIAN COMMUNITY. I
BELIEVE HE'S HERE IN THE
GALLERY COMING RIGHT UP. GOOD
MORNING. WHAT MORE MEMBERS YEAH
MY NAME IS LEO CISCO REPRESENT
MY PEOPLE THAN THE CHARM OF THE
CENTER OF THE RANCHERIA ATTACH
YOUR CATS RHYME I'M ALSO HERE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
NINE FIFTY SEVEN WHICH RATIFY
AN AMENDMENT TO THE SENATE WAS
A RANCHERIA TOUCHY OKAY TRIBE.
THE GAME COMPACT WITH THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. ON BEHALF OF THE
TECHIE OKAY TRIED ALEXA THANK
ASSEMBLYMAN RUDY SALAS FOR AS
LONG TIME CONTINUE SUPPORT FOR
PEOPLE AS WELL AS HIS
WILLINGNESS TO SPONSOR THE
RATIFICATION. OF A. B. IN I.
FIFTY SEVEN. SERVICE RENTERIA
BURN THAT SENT WORKINGS IN THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY CENTER
CALIFORNIA ABOUT FIVE MILES
SOUTH OF LAMAR CALIFORNIA IN
KINGS COUNTY. THE TRIBE THOSE
CURRENTLY OPERATES IN THIRTY
BUCKS A RESORT TWO THOUSAND
GAMING DEVICES FOR NINETEEN
NINETY NINE TRIBAL STATE GAMING
COMPACT BUT WE COME FROM VERY
HUMBLE BEGINNINGS NOVEMBER
THIRD NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE
CHANGE OUR LIVES FOREVER OUR
GAME OF FACILITY GIVE US
OPPORTUNITIES THAT OUR
ANCESTORS COULD ONLY DREAM OF
OUR PEOPLE USE THEIR CARS
CHICKEN COOPS AND WHEN THERE
ARE HOMES AVAILABLE THEY HAVE
MULTIPLE FAMILIES WHICH MEANT.
THAT THERE WERE AT LEAST TEN TO
TWELVE PEOPLE IN THE HOME
INSTEAD OF GOING TO SCHOOL OUR
FAMILIES WERE TO FEEL SUPER
FOOD ON THE TABLE WATER HAD TO
BE HEATED OR TO HAVE A WARM
BATH SOME HOMES AND EVEN HAVE
RUNNING WATER I AM PROUD TO SAY
THAT GAMING HAS ALLOWED US TO
PROVIDE HOUSING FOR PEOPLE
ELDERS ARE LIVING LONGER
BECAUSE WE CAN PROVIDE THEM THE
HEALTH INSURANCE. SO THEY CAN
RECEIVE THE PROPER HEALTH CARE
THAT THEY NEED WE HAVE A SOCIAL
SERVICES DEPARTMENT TO ASSIST
OUR COMMUNITY AND NOW ARE YOU
THERE GRADUATING GOING TO
COLLEGE WE ARE VERY PROUD TO
SAY THAT THEY CAN PICK ANY CALL
AS THEY WANT AND THE TRIBEWILL
PAY ONE HUNDRED PERCENT. OF
THAT BILL WE NOW EMPLOY OVER A
THOUSAND PEOPLE AT A CASINO
REPLY THAT WOULD BE PROVIDED
THEM WITH GOOD PAYING JOBS. AND
GREAT BENEFITS. WHEN THE TRIBE
FLOURISHES EVERYONE AROUND
BENEFITS SERVICE RENTERIA'S
ALSO FOSTERED A GOVERNMENT TO
GOVERNMENT RELATIONSHIP WITH
OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY. AS WELL AS
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT WITH A
DETERMINATION TO INCREASE THE
STANDARD OF LIVING AND QUALITY
OF LIFE FOR OUR TRAVELLING
MEMBERS AS WELL AS ALL OUR KING
COUNTY KINGS COUNTY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OUR TRIBE ESTABLISHED
SEVERAL ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
ENERGY ENTERPRISES THE JUDGE
PALACE CASINO RESORT BY CODY
ENTERTAINMENT CENTER YEAH OKAY
YES HOTEL IN HANFORD CALIFORNIA
SKOREA A RECENTLY PURCHASED
FARM THIRTY FARMS THE PURPOSE
OF THESE ENTERPRISES HAS
PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES TO
FULFILL THE NEEDS AND ASSIST IN
GAINING SELF SUFFICIENCY NOT
ONLY PROTECT YOUR CAT PEOPLE
BUT FOR THE ENTIRE KINGS COUNTY
COMMUNITY EVERYONE WILL BENEFIT
FROM THE TREMENDOUS RELATIONS
THAT HAS BEEN BUILT BY HER
TRIBE AND KINGS COUNTY AND WE
EXPECT THAT THIS RELATIONSHIP
WILL CONTINUE TO FLORIDA MANY
YEARS TO COME EARLIER THIS YEAR
OUR TRIBE AND KINGS COUNTY
SIGNED AN INTER GOVERNMENT
AGREEMENT. TO ALLOW
CONSTRUCTION OF A NEW FIRE
STATION. PUBLIC SAFETY ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT FOR KINGS COUNTY.
AS WELL AS THE EXPANSION OF THE
TETCHY PALACE CASINO RESORT THE
END OF IT INTERGOVERNMENTALAGREEMENTS WILL ALLOW
GOVERNMENT TO GOVERNMENT
RELATIONSHIP. BETWEEN OUR TRIBE
AND KINGS COUNTY TO GROW OVER
THE TERM OF THE AGREEMENT.
FOREGOING A STRONG PARTNERSHIP
LONG INTO THE FUTURE THE TOUCH
APOSTASY RESORT IS DOING ITS
ABSOLUTE BEST. AND CONTINUE TO
GET THROUGH THE COVERT PANDEMIC
WITH INCREASED PROTECTIONS BY
IMPLEMENTING VARIOUS POLICIES
INCLUDING A SAFETY AMBASSADOR
PROGRAM. COVE IN NINETEEN RE
OPENING IN PHASES L. BORDER
TRADE TO ENSURE THAT ALL THE
EMPLOYEES ARE WELL TRAINED WITH
REGARD TO COVER SAFETY
REQUIREMENTS THE NEW CONTACT
ENHANCES THE REGULATION OF
CLASS THREE GAMING. THAT
ANSWERS IT IS A FAIR AND HONEST
OPERATION. IN A WAY THAT
PROTECTS THE INTERESTS OF THE
TRIBE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ITS CITIZENS AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES UNDER THE NEW
COMPACT THE TRIBE IS AUTHORIZED
TO OPERATE UP TO THREE THOUSAND
GAME DEVICES OF KNOWLEDGEABLE
AND THEY'RE STILL THE TRUST FOR
THE TRIBE THE TRIBE IS REQUIRED
TO COVER ITS PROVIDERS SHARE OF
THE COSTS. INCURRED BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
PERFORMANCE OF ITS REGULATORY
DUTIES. TO THE INDIAN GAMING
SPECIAL DISTRIBUTION FUND THE
LICENSING REGULATORY
ENVIRONMENT MEDICATION PAYCHECK
PROTECTION LABOR. PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SAFETY PROVISIONS ARE
SIMILAR TO OTHER RECENT
CONTACTS. WITH MANY REVISIONS
WHICH GREATLY IMPROVE THE
GOVERNMENT TO GOVERNMENT
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE CENTER
WAS A RANCHERIA TOUCHY OKAY
TRIBE. AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE ARE PLEASED THAT
GOVERNOR SAM AND HIS TRAVEL
NEGOTIATORS ENEMY MARK IN THE
FAMILY OUR SUPPORT OF THIS
FRAMEWORK AND ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
TODAY WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
OF THE V. NINETY SEVEN. THANK
YOU THANK YOU CHAIRMAN CISCO
MEMBERS DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. SEEING NO QUESTIONS-
CHAIRMAN I BUT I BELIEVE YOUR
CASINO HAS ROUGHLY TWO THOUSAND
SLOT MACHINES ARE YOU PLANNING
ON EXPANDING THAT NUMBER- SINCE
THE NEW CONTACT ALLOWS FOR UP
TO THREE THOUSAND. WELL WE DO
PLAN ON THE EXPANDING WHEN
THAT'S- WHEN IT'S SUITABLE IN
THE SAFETY OF OTHERS ARE- BUT
STRONGLY CONSIDER THAT'S WE
WILL SOON BEGIN THE EXPANSION
OF THE CASINO SHE THAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CHAIRMAN CISCO
WILL NOW- HERE FROM MARIO EDT A
AND KRISTEN MARTIN FROM UNITE I
BELIEVE BOTH ARE HERE WITH US
TODAY ON ZERO. YES THANK YOU-
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN DIED AND
MEMBERS GOOD MORNING TO GERMAN
CISCO CHAIRMAN SIMON AND MR
UGLY OF THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
MY NAME IS MARIO YOU DID YEAH
AND ON THE WESTERN POLITICAL
DIRECTOR WITH UNITE HERE.
INTERNATIONAL UNION THE CASINO
WORKERS UNION IN NORTH AMERICA.
OUR MEMBERS ARE OVERWHELMINGLY
PEOPLE OF COLOR IMMIGRANTS AND
WOMEN AND IN CALIFORNIA WERE
PROUD THAT SEVEN THOUSAND OF
OUR MEMBERS WORKING. NINE
TRIBAL CASINOS ACROSS THE STATE
WHERE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS ENSURE DIGNITY
RESPECT AND FAIR WAGES AND
BENEFITS. UNITE HERE HAS NOT
OPPOSED TO CONTACT IN THE
LEGISLATURE FOR MORE THAN FORTY
YEARS. WE HAVE NOT DONE SO
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THAT THE
TRIBAL LABOR RELATIONS
ORDINANCES INCORPORATED INTO
CONTACTS SINCE THEN HAVE
PROTECTED WORKERS ABILITY TO
FREELY ASSOCIATE AND ORGANIZE
AND WE DO NOT STAND BEFORE YOU
THIS MORNING IN OPPOSITION TO
EITHER THE SANTA ROSA NOR THE
MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA COMPACTS.
HOWEVER WE MUST EXPRESS
SIGNIFICANT CONCERN ABOUT THE
STATUS OF CASINO WORKER RIGHTS
IN CALIFORNIA. FOR THREE
REASONS MOST FUNDAMENTALLY WERE
WORRIED ABOUT THE STATE'S
ENFORCEMENT OF ALL TRIBAL LABOR
RELATIONS ORDINANCE SAYS IN
LIGHT OF THE ACTIONS OF
MANAGEMENT THAT'S A QANTAS YOU
KNOW RESORT IN SAN DIEGO
SOMETHING WHICH CHAIRMAN DIED.
AND MR BOLDLY MADE MENTION OF
EARLIER IN THIS HEARING THE
FACT IS THAT THE SYCUAN BAND OF
THE KUMEYAAY NATION HAS BEEN
OPENLY FLOUTING THE TRIBAL
LABOR RELATIONS ORDINANCE IN
THEIR CONTACT AT THAT THIS YOU
KNOW FOR CLOSE TO TWO YEARS.
WORKERS AT SAQUON HELD THEIR
FIRST COMMITTEE MEETING IN THE
SUMMER OF TWENTY NINETEEN AND
THEY ASKED THE TRIBE TO HONOR
THE T. L. R. O. IN NOVEMBER OF
THAT YEAR. BUT SAQUON TURNED
AROUND. AND THEY STARTED UNION
BUSTING THEY BROUGHT AN ANTI
UNION CONSULTANTS AND FORCE THE
WORKERS INTO MEETINGS TO BAD
MOUTH THE UNION THEN THEY
TURNED AROUND AND JUST ABOUT
THE T. L. R. O. AS SUCH AND
THEY HAVEN'T STOPPED. DESPITE
THE FACT THAT ON DECEMBER TENTH
TWENTY TWENTY U. S. DISTRICT
COURT FOR SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
ORDERED SAQUON TO ARBITRATE ITS
DISPUTE WITH THE UNION. THE
TRIBE CONTINUES TO DRAG ITS
FEET AND REFUSES TO ARBITRATE.
SO KWAN APPEALED AND THAT CASE
IS PENDING BEFORE THE NINTH
CIRCUIT WHAT'S MORE. ELEVEN
TRIBES HAVE BROUGHT SUIT
AGAINST THE STATE. ARGUING
AGAINST THE APPROPRIATENESS OF
THE T. L. R. O. AS A SUBJECT OF
COMPACT NEGOTIATIONS. THOSE
CASES ARE ALSO PENDING IN
FEDERAL COURT. AND FINALLY WE
MUST NOTE THAT JUST LAST MONTH
FOR THE THIRD TIME IN FIVE
YEARS. THE TRIBAL LABOR
SOVEREIGNTY ACT A BILL THAT
WOULD EXEMPT TRIBAL CASINOS
FROM THE NATIONAL LABOR
RELATIONS ACT. WAS PUT FORWARD
IN CONGRESS. IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THE SAME BILL PASSED THE HOUSE
AND CAME A FEW VOTES SHY OF
PASSAGE IN THE UNITED STATES
SENATE. THIS MEANS THAT WHILE
IN CONGRESS NUMEROUS TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE ATTEMPTING TO
EXEMPT THEMSELVES FROM FEDERAL
LABOR LAW AT THE SAME TIME IN
CALIFORNIA. A DOZEN TRIBES ARE
ATTEMPTING TO GET AROUND THE
LABOR PROTECTIONS INCORPORATED
INTO TRIBAL STATE COMPACTS.
UNITE HERE RECOGNIZES AND
AFFIRMS THE RIGHT OF TRIBAL
SOVEREIGNTY. WE WELL KNOW THAT
THE SANTA ROSA INDIAN COMMUNITY
AND GERMAN CISCO. AND THE
MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA CHAIRMAN
SIMON DO NOT RUN SAQUON CASINO
RESORT AND THEY ARE NOT PARTIES
TO THE LAWSUIT SEEKING TO
DISALLOW LABOR RIGHTS. FROM
BEING A SUBJECT OF TRIBAL STATE
COMPACT IN CALIFORNIA. WE DO
KNOW THAT THE MIDDLETOWN
RANCHERIA IS A MEMBER OF THE
NATIONAL INDIAN GAMING
ASSOCIATION. WHICH IN ITS OWN
WORDS PRIORITIZED AND DEVOTED
SIGNIFICANT EFFORT. TO PASS THE
TRIBAL LABOR SOVEREIGNTY ACT
WHAT ALSO RECOGNIZE INDUSTRIAL
PATTERNS AND WE AFFIRM THE
RIGHT OF WORKERS TO FREELY
ASSOCIATE UNTIL MORGAN EYES
THEMSELVES INTO A UNION IF THEY
SO CHOOSE. CALIFORNIA TRIBAL
GAMING IS A NINE BILLION DOLLAR
INDUSTRY WHERE NO LESS THAN A
DOZEN EMPLOYERS ARE SEEKING TO
ELIMINATE. TRIBAL STATE COMPACT
ENSHRINED LABOR RIGHTS WELL AT
THE SAME TIME THE INDUSTRY'S
CORE NATIONAL TRADE
ASSOCIATION. SEEKS TO UNDO THE
SAME RIGHTS FEDERALLY. FOR THE
RECORD WE REGISTER OUR CONCERN
WITH THE STATUS YOU KNOW WORKER
ORGANIZING RIGHTS. AND WE ASKED
THE COMMITTEE TO TAKE NOTE OF
THESE FACTS MISS MARTIN. GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS YOU
HI MY NAME IS KRISTEN MARTIN-I'M WITH THE LAW FIRM OF THE
CRACK IN GOVERNMENT IN
SALISBURY AND I'M GENERAL
COUNSEL TO UNITE HERE
INTERNATIONAL UNION THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION GIVES
THE LEGISLATURE AN IMPORTANT
ROLE IN DECIDING THE TERMS OF
TRIBAL GAMING COMPACTS. ARTICLE
FOUR SECTION NINETEEN ACCESS OF
THE GOVERNOR YOU GO SHOOTING
CONCLUDES COMPAQ'S BUT THOSE
CONTACTS ARE SUBJECT TO THE
RATIFICATION OF THE LEGISLATURE
IN THIS FORMULA THE LEGISLATURE
IS NOT A RUBBER STAMP THE
LEGISLATURE'S JOB IS TO
CAREFULLY REVIEW AND CONSIDER
ALL PROVISIONS OF A PROPOSED
COMPACT JUST AS IT WOULD O
WITH ANY OTHER BILL THAT COMES
BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
LEGISLATURE CAN DEFINE DEFINE
EXCUSE ME TO RATIFY A CONTRACT
CONTACT IF IT'S NOT SATISFIED
WITH THE PROPOSED TERMS SOME
HAVE POINTED OUT THAT THE
INDIAN GAMING REGULATORY ACT
PERMITS TRIBES TO SUE THE STATE
FOR NEGOTIATING IN BAD FAITH.
WHAT DID IT MEAN GAMING
REGULATORY ACT ACTUALLY SAYS IS
THAT A TRY MISSOURI STATE FOR
FAILING TO RESPOND TO THE
TRIBE'S REQUEST TO NEGOTIATE A
CONTRACT IN GOOD FAITH THE
LEGISLATURE DOES NOT. FAIL TO
RESPOND TO REQUESTSTO
NEGOTIATE A CONTRACT IN GOOD
FAITH. WHEN THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDERS THE TERMS OF THE
PROPOSED COMPACT RESENTED YOUR
RATIFICATION THE LEGISLATURE I
WOULD SUBMIT MUST CONSIDER THAT
WHETHER THE TERMS ARE FAIR. ARE
CONSISTENT WITH THE INDIAN
GAMING REGULATORY ACT AND WILL
SERVE CALIFORNIA'S LEGITIMATE
INTERESTS I'M IN THE
LEGISLATURE DOES THIS IT ACTS
IN GOOD FAITH IT EXERCISES ITS
CONSTITUTIONAL DUTY TO DECIDE
WHETHER OR NOT TO RATIFY A CALL
I WOULD ARGUE IT CAN NOT BE BAD
FAITH TO DO WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION SAYS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MUST YOU. MISTER
YOU DID HEAR REFERENCED THE
CHALLENGES WE FACE WITH
SUPPOSED TO CLIMB DOWN. LET ME
LET ME JUST ADD A LITTLE BIT TO
WHAT HE SAYS FOR NEARLY TWO
YEARS THE SYCUAN BAND HAS
VIOLATED LABOR RELATIONS
PROVISIONS OF ITS CONTRACT WITH
CALIFORNIA AND THERE'S NO
GENUINE DISPUTE ABOUT THIS
WHATSOEVER. THE COMPACT
REQUIRES TO BOND TO ADOPT AND
MAINTAIN THE TRIBAL LABOR
RELATIONS WORK AND THAT TRIBAL
LABOR RELATIONS ORDINANCE SAYS
THAT IF THE UNION MAKES A
SERIES OF PROMISES JUST ONE THE
BENEFIT THAT FIVE MINUTES IS
ENOUGH THOMAS IS NOT TO STRIKE
NOT THE TICKET NOT TO BOYCOTT
NOT THE POPE WHAT ARE CALLED
ATTACK WEBSITES. NOT EVEN
DISPARAGE THE TRIBE THE PURPOSE
OF ORGANIZING AND NOT TO
INTERFERE IN TRIBAL GOVERNMENT
ELECTIONS THE BROAD
RESTRICTIONS ON THE UNION'S
RIGHT OF FREE SPEECH AND THE
UNIONS AND THE LABOR RIGHTS OF
THE EMPLOYEES THE UNION MAKES
THOSE PROMISES SAID MON MON
REMAIN NEUTRAL AND ALLOW
WORKERS TO ORGANIZE A UNION
WITHOUT INTERFERENCE IN OCTOBER
TWENTY NINETEEN UNITE HERE
LOCAL THIRTY WHICH OPERATES IN
SAN DIEGO COUNTY MADE THOSE
BOXES THE CROWD RESPONDED THAT
THE COMPACT LABOR RELATIONS
PROVISIONS ARE INVALID NOW THAT
THEPUBLIC RELATIONS ORDINANCE
ALLOWS THE UNION TO ENFORCE THE
DEALERS TERMS THROUGH
ARBITRATION THE LOCAL THIRTY
ASK ONE CARPENTRY AND UPON
REVIEW SO NOT ONLY REFUSED TO
COMPLY WITH THE SUBSTANTIVE
PROVISIONS OF THE TRIBAL LABOR
RELATIONS ORDINANCE BUT IT ALSO
REFUSED TO. USE THE DISPUTE
RESOLUTION PROCESS IN THAT
ORDINANCE. IN A NEUTRAL THIRD
PARTY ARBITRATOR DECIDE WHO IS
RIGHT IN THAT INITIAL DISPUTE.
AND AS MR YOU DO THE EXPLAINING
SO KANN ALSO DID NOT REMAIN
NEUTRAL ALLOW THE WORKERS TO
ORGANIZE A UNION WITHOUT
INTERFERENCE WHICH IS THE CORE
PROMISE OF THE TRIBAL LABOR
RELATIONS BOARD THIS IS LIKELY
NOT WHAT THE MEMBERS OF THIS
LEGISLATURE WHO VOTED IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN TO RATIFY IT TOOK
MONTHS COMPACT. EXPECTED OR
INTENDED WHEN THEY SOLD OUT. NO
ONE'S COMPACT CONTAINS A
DISPUTE RESOLUTION PROCESS THAT
APPLIES WHEN EITHER THE STATE
OR THE TRIBE REACHES THE
CONTACTS ARE RETAINS THE LABOR
RELATIONS AND THE OTHER
MATERIAL PROVISIONS OF THE
CONTACT. THAT WAS A THIRTY DAY
WRITTEN NOTICE TO CURE FOLLOWED
BY A SUIT IN FEDERAL COURT FOR
A DECLARATION THAT THE OTHER
PARTY HAS MATERIALLY BREACH THE
COMPOUND THE COURT ISSUES THAT
DECLARATION AND THE VIOLATIONS
CONTINUE THAN THE PARTY
BRINGING THAT SUIT CLAIMING A
VIOLATION. CAN UNILATERALLY
TERMINATE THE CALL THAT'S WHAT
THE QUALMS CONTACT SEX IN THE
IN THE SITUATION I DESCRIBED IN
THE STREET IT IS ROB WITH
RESPECT TO LABOR RELATIONS THAT
PROCESS PROVED TO BE
INEFFECTIVE FOR TWO REASONS. AT
THE OUTSET IT DIDN'T TO TURKS
UPON FROM VIOLATING. A COMPLEX
WEB OF RELATIONSHIPS AND THEN
THE PROMPT EVEN MORE
IMPORTANTLY THE STATE DID NOT
USE THIS PROCESS TO TRY TO
ENFORCE THE COMPACT IT AND
GRADUATED WITH THE STATE DID
NOT. WE DON'T KNOW WHETHER THE
STATE GAVE SOMEONE A NOTICED
YOU'RE THAT'S NOT PUBLIC
INFORMATION ABOUT THIS WEEK
THEY DID NOT. ZERO ONE
PARTICULAR TORY JUDGMENT WHICH
WOULD'VE FELT. BY WITH THE LEAD
LABOR RELATIONS PROVISIONS OF
THE COMPACT YEAH UNITE HERE DID
SEE AVAILABLE IN THE DISTRICT
FOUR AND AS PEOPLE HAVE STAYED
IN THAT CASE IS NOW PENDING
BEFORE THE NINTH CIRCUIT BUT
IT'S BEEN A LONG PROCESS NEARLY
TWO YEARS AND WE HAVE A LONG
PROCESS. AHEAD OF THIS PROCESS
THIS LEGAL PROCESS WILL
PROBABLY TAKE LONGER. I THANK
I'M CERTAIN THIS PROCESS WILL
TAKE LONGER THAN HAVE THE STATE
THE STATE BROUGHT THE INITIAL
SUIT. UNDER THE DISPUTE
RESOLUTION PROVISION OF THE
CONTRACT ITSELF AND IN THE
INTERIM. ONE IS ABLE TO
DISREGARD ENTIRELY ITS
OBLIGATIONS UNDER THE CONTRACT
LABOR RELATIONS PROVISION SPEED
IS IMPORTANT WHAT ORGANIZED
EVERY DAY THAT SAQUON CAN DELAY
ITS COMPLIANCE WITH THE KEELER
RO MAKES IT MORE LIKELY THAT
WORKERS WILL BECOME DEMORALIZED
AND THEY WILL GIVE UP ON THEIR-
BUT HAVING THE UNION IS
RELEVANT TO THIS CASE ISN'T
UNIQUE TO THE QUAN MR DELAY IS
A STANDARD PLAYBOOK IN A
PRIVATE SECTOR EMPLOYERS ACROSS
INDUSTRIES USE THE SMART UNION
ORGANIZER YOU COULD YOU WRAP UP
PLEASE. YES AND- CALIFORNIA
SHOULD LEARN FROM EXPERIENCE
WITH THE QUAN- AND IT SHOULD BE
WE BELIEVE IT SHOULD NEGOTIATE
A DISPUTE RESOLUTION
PROCEDURES- THAT STRENGTHEN THE
STATE'S HANDS IF THERE'S A
VIOLATION I JUST WANT TO
CORRECT SOMETHING THAT MR
VOCALLY SAD. THE COMPACT IT'LL
BE FOR YOU DON'T REPLICATE
WHAT'S IN THIS APARTMENT
COMPLEX ACTUALLY MAKE THE
PROCESS MORE TIME CONSUMING BUT
NOT AN ALTERNATE BETWEEN
ARBITRATION AND USING THE
PROCESSES OF BONDS COMPANIES
RIGHT. WHAT THE PROPOSED
CONTRACT AND HIS SUBSEQUENT
EXHAUSTING THE SECTION THREE
POINT OUT THIRTEEN POINT OF
DISPUTE RESOLUTION PROCEDURES
PROVISIONS WHICH IS THE
ARBITRATION. ONLY AFTER DOING
THAT IN THIS STATE INVOKE. THE
DECLARATORY RELIEF PROVISIONS
WE THAT THEY PROF INJURED BE I
HAPPY TO MY OR HOW THANK YOU
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS FOR
MEMBERS DID FOR THE MEMBERS
BECAUSE I HAD A NUMBER OF
MEMBERS- CONTACT ME. REGARDING
THIS TESTIMONY SINCE IT WASN'T
REALLY IN REFERENCE TO EITHER
ONE OF THE TRIBES HERE I FELT
IT WAS- IMPORTANT THAT OUR
MEMBERS UNDERSTAND-
PARTICULARLY IN THE SPIRIT OF
THESE- CONTACTS OVER THE YEARS
WITH LABOR AND THE GREAT
RELATIONSHIPS THAT- THE TRIBES
OF HAD ALSO THIS COMMITTEE'S
HAD WITH UNITE HERE. AND THE
COOPERATIVE NATURE THAT IT WAS
IMPORTANT FOR THE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE TO GET A LITTLE
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF- WHAT
WHAT'S WHAT'S GOING ON- WITH-
THE LAWSUITS JUST TO GET
UPDATED SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO PUBLIC
COMMENT. IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
GALLERY WISHES TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY SEEING NONE.
ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE. SEEING NONE. THANK
YOU MORE LIVE NOW MOVE ON TO
ANYONE WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
THE TELECONFERENCE OR VINCE
MODERATOR IF YOU PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITED SATISFIED
WE'LL BEGIN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH
TO COMMENT AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO PRESS ONE
METER TO COMMENT AND MODERATOR-
CAN YOU PLEASE GIVE ME THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE WAITING
TO TESTIFY WHEN YOU HAVE A
POLICE. I'M SHOWING THAT THE
PEOPLE OF SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK VERY GOOD LET'S
PROCEED I'M GOING TO GO TO THE
LINE TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS SUSAN
JOHNSON I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
NATIONS INDIAN GAMING
NOW GO TO LINE. ELEVEN. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS DAVID ROBINSON
KING COUNTY SHERIFF IN- THE
CENTRAL VALLEY HERE WITH THE
TALK TO YOU OKAY TRIDENT'S
STRONG SUPPORT WE APPRECIATE
OUR RELATIONSHIP WITH THEM
THANK YOU THANK YOU WINE AND.
YES THIS IS BILL LYNCH WITH
THE- KING COUNTY FIRE
DEPARTMENT FIRE CHIEF- IN
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE- TACHI-
OKAY- PROPOSAL- WE'VE GOT A
LONG AND FRUITFUL RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE TRIBE AND- WE WISH TO
CONTINUE THAT RELATIONSHIP AND-
YOUR OUTSTANDING THINGS FOR OUR
COMMUNITY AND I JUST WONDER FOR
THAT. THANK YOU THANK YOU KEITH
THAT'S CALLER LINE. FOURTEEN.
ONE FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
I WILL MAKE ONE. CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER WOULD YOU BUY
AND THE CANADIENS REPRESENTING
ROBERT INTO SEEING YOUR
CHAIRMAN WE WISH TO RECORD OUR
SUPPORT FOR RATIFICATION OF THE
MIDDLE TOWN CENTER OF THE
COMEBACKS THANK YOU THANK YOU
SURE THERE IS O ONE ELSE TO
SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO SPEAK
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR. BUT THAT DOES IT FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT I'D I I'D I'M
NOT SURE I ASK FOR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION ON THE ON THAT CAN
SOMEBODY I DID NOT SUGGEST
PUBLIC COMEDY IN GENERAL OKAY
SO THANK YOU- MODERATOR PLEASE
LET ME- THANK PERSONALLY THANK
MR WELL HELLO- IT FOR FILLING
IN FOR MISS NAME MARK TODAY I
ALSO WANT TO THANK THE TRIBAL
CHAIRS UNITE HERE FOR THEIR
COMMENTS. ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU
TO ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY AS A REMINDER
IF YOU ARE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR ****
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE SENATE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY AND
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD THANK
YOU AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION. IS ADJOURNED.